[Música]
pasamos ahora la economía ya está aquí
en el estudio jorge hurtado para
hablarnos de las novedades en este
comienzo de semana jorge muy buenas
noches bienvenidos comenzamos con
indicadores porque fue un muy mal día
para las acciones en wall street'
santiago las acciones estadounidenses
cayeron a su nivel más bajo en 13 meses
la venta generalizada comenzó la semana
pasada tras las dudas de los inversores
sobre la capacidad de la reserva federal
para controlar la inflación el índice de
la volatilidad vix conocido como el
índice del miedo alcanzó su nivel más
alto en dos meses la caída se extendió a
los productores de energía el grupo se
desplomó un 8% con la caída del crudo
esto se debe a preocupaciones combinadas
vinculadas a los temas geopolíticos los
confinamientos en china y el temor
inflacionario que pesa en los activos de
riesgo e incide sobre todo en la
volatilidad de los mercados las cripto
monedas y las materias primas las
tecnológicas no se salvaron empresas
como tesla amazon y envidia cayeron en
al menos un 5% ese índice ha caído 9 por
ciento tras el anuncio del aumento de
los tipos de interés en europa el
pesimismo también llegó las acciones
alcanzaron mínimos de 2 es liderada por
sectores como el de viajes ocio y el
tecnológico y la bolsa es latina no se
salvaron tampoco el índice es amp y
merval de las acciones de empresas
líderes que cotizan en la bolsa de
comercio de buenos aires cerró con una
caída del 4,92 por ciento hablemos ahora
de ese ambicioso embargo del petróleo
ruso por parte de algunos países
europeos pero hay algunos que son
dependientes de este petróleo y están
bloqueando esta medida la univer europea
reconoce que hay algunos avances en
estas negociaciones mientras que los
países más dependientes piden mayores
garantías para asegurar el
abastecimiento la presidenta de la
comisión europea úrsula poner online no
pudo convencer el primer ministro
húngaro de apoyar las sanciones
comunitarias al petróleo ruso hungría
dice que esta medida renovaría
arruinaría su economía y hungría y otros
países de europa central y del este como
eslovaquia república checa y bulgaria se
oponen a este tipo de sanciones debido a
su dependencia enorme de la de moscú
principalmente este embargo energético
es un punto de inflexión para la unidad
europea frente a moscú las primeras
discusiones comenzaron con la
negociación del veto del carbón ruso a
principios de abril
sexto paquete de sanciones se negocia
luego de que gazprom la semiestatal rusa
cortará el gas a polonia y bulgaria por
negarse a pagarlo en rublos ahora la
comisión europea teme que esto pueda
repetirse con otros estados a mediados y
finales de mayo que es cuando vence en
el resto de los contratos los países del
g7 acordaron también vetar gradualmente
el petróleo ruso hablemos ahora de temas
de américa latina' vamos a méxico porque
la inflación continúa al alza esto
quiere decir la tortilla se va a poner
más cara en ese país le preocupa la
gente allí sin duda alguna méxico
reportó una inflación general anual del
7 68 por ciento en abril es el nivel más
alto santiago desde enero de 2001 con
fuertes alza sobre todo en los alimentos
como bien mencionabas el aumento
interanual fue del 0.54 por ciento según
el instituto nacional de estadísticas y
geografía los productos con mayor
aumento mensual en su precio fueron el
chile serrano con un 25 65% el jitomate
con 20 como 23 por ciento y el aguacate
con 13 94% productos básicos por
supuesto de la dieta mexicana ahí los
precios de los agropecuarios aumentaron
un 14 36 por ciento
a nivel anual para este jueves espera la
reunión del banco central mexicano se
prevén nuevos aumentos en la tasa de
interés en respuesta a la inflación
durante su última reunión recordemos que
el emisor incrementó la tasa de interés
a el 65 %
pues a medirse entonces con los tacos
allí en mexico hablemos ahora para las
personas que tienen ahorros en cripto
monedas esto les va a interesar porque
el bitcoin registró la caída del 50 por
ciento desde su máximo esto por el temor
a los activos de riesgo solamente este
lunes la mayor cripto moneda que hay un
11 por ciento y se ubicó en los 30 mil
dólares pero mientras la cripta de
divisas se ha desplomado el presidente
salvadoreño en allí buque le anunció la
compra de 500 bitcoin por más de 15 tres
millones de dólares con esa compra el
salvador tiene alrededor de 2300 monedas
pero se desconoce qué ha hecho con los
activos digitales el salvador ya cumplió
ocho meses desde que entró en vigencia
esta ley bitcoin que pone
junto al dólar como una moneda en curso
legal jorge muchas gracias por esta
actualización de las noticias de
economía y ya estamos listos para el
debate aquí en directo américa
[Música]